thank you precision we can take by
accompanying the president the
constitutional governor of the state of
aguascalientes martín orozco sandoval
lower california francisco arturo vega de
lamadrid
constitutional governor of the state of
lower california sur carlos mendoza davis
the constitutional governor of the state
of campeche alejandro  Rafael Moreno
Cardenas
Constitutional Governor of the State of
Chiapas Rutilio Cruz Escandón Cadenas
Coahuila Miguel Ángel Riquelme Solís
Head of Government of Mexico City
Claudia Sheinbaum Pardo
Constitutional Governor of the State of
Durango José Rosas Aispuro Torres
Mexico  alfredo del mazo massa
the constitutional governor of the state
of jalisco enrique alfaro ramírez
constitutional governor of the state of
Guerrero héctor antonio astudillo flores
Largo o  Mar Fayad Meneses
Constitutional Governor of the State of
Michoacán Silvano Aureoles Rabbit
Nayarit Antonio Echevarría García
Constitutional Governor of the State
of Nuevo León Jaime Rodríguez Calderón
Constitutional Governor of the State of
Oaxaca Alejandro Murat Hinojosa
Puebla Guillermo Pacheco Pulido
Governor  Constitutional Governor of the State of
Querétaro Francisco Domínguez Servién
Constitutional Governor of the State of
Quintana Roo Carlos Manuel
Joaquín González
Constitutional Governor of the State of
Sinaloa Quirino Ordaz Coppel
Sonora Claudia Pavlovich Arellano
Constitutional Governor of the State of
Tabasco Adán Augusto López Hernández
Constitutional Governor of the  State of
Tamaulipas Francisco García Cabeza de
Vaca
Constitutional Governor of the State of
Tlaxcala Marco Antonio Reyna Rodríguez
V  eracruz cuitláhuac garcía jiménez
constitutional governor of the state of
yucatán mauricio vila dosal
zacatecas alejandro tello cristerna
secretary of foreign relations
marcelo ebrard casaubón
secretary of the navy admiral josé
rafael ojeda durán
general secretary of national defense
luís crescencio sandoval
gonzález secretary of the interior  olga sánchez
lamb
the secretary of finance and
public credit carlos manuel for his ladies aunts
secretary of economy thanks the brand
is colin
head of office of the presidency
alfonso romo garza
of the confederation of
industrial chambers accompany us to jose
abugaber
with alberto porras
president of the  chamber of deputies
porfirio muñoz ledo
president of the council
business coordinator carlos salazar lomelín
the municipal president of tijuana juan
manuel gastélum buenosrostro
from the confederation of workers
of mexico carlos acevedo
of human rights father  e solalinde
governor of san luís potosí juan
manuel races
representatives of the
indigenous communities amalia de torralba
representative of the evangelical community
arturo favela
president of the association of banks of
mexico luis nino de rivera
president of concanaco josé manuel
lópez campus
welcomes this act of unity in  defense of
the dignity of mexico and in favor of
friendship for the people of the united
states the constitutional president of the
united mexican states andrés
manuel lópez obrador
[Applause]
all the senators and deputies
present
to the people of tijuana representatives
of organizations of the  civil society
officials of the three levels of
government representatives of the
media and those who see us live
and direct through the television broadcast
that reaches the entire country via the internet to
the entire world you are all
welcome let us
listen to the message of the
secretary of  foreign relations
bachelor s  arcelo ebrard casaubón
ladies, gentlemen, governors,
compañeras, comrades, secretaries,
secretaries,
representatives of the private sector,
distinguished guests, distinguished guests,
and compañeras, comrades,
I have just arrived from Washington
if you notice I am a little tired, it is because
we spent many hours working to
try to avoid how they finally
managed to impose the tariffs on us
mexico on monday
I want to share with you
what the problem was with the famous
rates
or because the president of the
republic asked us to speak
to the economy secretary
doctor graciela márquez to the
agriculture secretary
here engineer víctor villalobos
thank you very much  víctor for the support that he tells us
now on this trip of
course
to the team of the foreign relations sect
the mexican embassy instructed us all
to do everything possible to
be patient but not to stop
raising concerns and arguments  in
mexico
to avoid  ry to persuade that this would not
happen
and why
what would be the effect of those tariffs
first of the 5th after the 10th
after the 15th or 20th
what would be the impact that it would have
for mexico
the first impact
is that there would be a significant drop in
investment there would be  a significant drop in
the number of jobs, perhaps we estimate
without exaggerating that more than 900,000
people could have lost their
jobs because at the time
a tariff is applied and a product is more
expensive
and it is more difficult to export it
and communicate with  The United States, well, at that
moment comes a fall in the
national economy, which means that the
loss of jobs, the
increase in prices, and the most serious thing
that could be the tariffs,
since they are practically imposed, it is now unfeasible for us to
have a free trade agreement
with the United States because  you
can't have both things, it's not only the
impact
of 5 of 10 percent, but how it is to
change a system where you have a
free trade agreement  by another
system where there is a
unilateral fixation of tariffs
by the us and then their return through
mexico and so on, what we
call a trade war
and the president was very worried
about the jobs that were going to be lost
and why they could be lost  the possibility
also
of ratifying the
free trade agreement with the united states and
canada this year
so the seriousness of things
and that is why he ordered
that we go to washington that same day
to make this negotiation
at the end of the day
we cannot say that we won  all the
points that mexico raised because that
would not be such a thing to say if we achieve things
if we achieve the most important thing that on
monday there will be
no tariffs we will not have or lose jobs
and we will lose the possibility of
ratifying the free trade agreement  and
we are going to have a situation in
which families have to suffer
from price increases and economic difficulties, and
that panorama is far away and from e  From our
point of view, with the guidance that
the President of the Republic gave us, we have
been successful, but this does not
mean that we are not going to be
monitoring it and that we should not be very
applied in the relationship between Mexico and the United States. It
does not mean that  Let's forget now, we are
going to have to work very hard in
the coming months to defend
Mexico and try and avoid any
decision that could affect us.
Today, I also want to inform you, on the
instructions of the president, that an agreement
was reached in
favor of Mexico
that the tariff no longer applies.  that is the
most important thing that is the most important thing
because I already explained that the impact would have been very
serious
what we said
what is the origin of the problem of these
rates
what we say is that the people who
come to our country and cross our
country is to stay in mexico to go
to the usa they have to register because if
we can't register them then we can't
know who they are and we can't
protect them  er
we said and explained that the government of
mexico
the president of the republic with the
support of the congress of the union that
by the way I see here in front of
many friends of the congress
ricardo monreal thank you for
joining us riccardo
tatiana who does not have
mario Delgado  there are many and many
comrades
the congress
greets all of them with great affection of
course
that the congress of the union decided that
the national guard be instituted in
mexico and that it will cover the entire
national territory including our
southern border and the northern border
we said we said
and today the
North Americans have decided they have
decided to return to Mexico 8000
people who are waiting for their
hearing in the US for asylum and those
people Mexico is offering them
support and backing and we will continue to
do so and the President
of the Republic has asked us  And so we let
it be known that in Mexico, due to our principles and
convictions of brotherhood, those
people in  our territory while they
are in mexico
we are going to be in solidarity with
them in solidarity and in solidarity and we are going to
protect their human rights
we said
and that is very important and what i want to
underline is
that we believe that the only solution to
the migratory flow is for people to have
options  where they live and that they do not have to
emigrate forcibly due to poverty and
that might seem very obvious
but it is very difficult to
get a government like the current US government to
recognize in a
public document that what Mexico is saying
is correct it
even
put it like this
mexico the united states reiterated the
declaration of december 18, 2018
in which both countries committed to
strengthening and expanding
bilateral cooperation to promote economic development
and increase investment in
southern mexico and central america to create
a zone of prosperity for both countries
recognize the strong links between
economic growth in southern
mexico  co and the success of promoting the
prosperity of good governance and
security in central america the usa reiterated
its approval of the comprehensive development plan
launched by the government of
mexico in conjunction with the governments of
salvador guatemala and honduras to
promote these goals
mexico and the usa
leaders will do the work with
national and international partners to
build a prosperous and secure Central America
and thus address the
underlying causes of migration with the
goal that citizens can
build better lives for themselves and their
families at home in short
there are no fees on Monday  We
promised that those who are in
our territory on their way to the United States tell us, we
will register it and it will be an
orderly and regular process,
and they promised to respect
human rights and support the
comprehensive development plan presented by our
president and led by him to
Central America so that people have
alternatives in their places of origin  igen
we win everything but if we win that there are
no fees and as I told the
president of the republic when I
gave him my report there are no fees
president and we leave with our dignity
intact thank you very much
we must take a seat let's
listen to the message of the
representative of the  indigenous communities
amalia tello torralba
tijuana
i have had so much dealing with my song
owner tijuana i having those two
me when i sing data and i don't take
lockers from where they were said year 18
san quintín who fell
juninho and a north never in all action
and kick and chicanas  there is a very good
afternoon president of the united
mexican states licentiate andrés manuel lópez
obrador
good afternoon gentlemen governors
legislators and legislators
social leaders countrymen and countrymen from all over
mexico
and also
to all citizens from
various parts of the world who
accompany us and listen to us  through the
internet we are all over the world it
is today here and  n this city of
tijuana where the northern border begins
today we are here thousands of free men and
women responding to
your call as president of mexico
to celebrate unity, dignity but
also friendship with the sister people
of the united states of america and with  the other
peoples of the world
on this occasion I am the spokesperson for the
indigenous peoples of these lands,
especially the agricultural day laborers
who,
like many others out of necessity, have
had to emigrate to the north of our
country, leaving our peoples and
communities behind to seek a
new survival.
from the valley of san quintín, a
place that you, mr. president of
mexico, have visited several times
and, above all, you know the situation very well
and from where
we ask you to receive the solidarity and
support of the indigenous peoples of mexico
this call represents the feelings of the
mexicans and  represents
the legitimacy defense of the dignity of
our nation and a call for peace  and
harmony before the world
that is so necessary in these moments
of rapid,
accelerated and also profound change, for this
reason the indigenous peoples of Mexico
are here present with you,
here we are,
just as our countrymen and also
our ancestors had in
the independence movement
the reform and
Today we are accompanying the Mexican revolution with the movement of
the fourth national transformation that is
so necessary for our country,
in particular for the areas most
abandoned by the so-called civilizational development.
In our experience as
indigenous peoples on this and the other side of the
border, we have learned that the  Dialogue
and words are the best ways
for understanding and peaceful coexistence,
and this is the message that we want to
convey
to society and to our present governments.
We want to express a message of
brotherhood and fraternity with the indigenous peoples
of the United States of America, especially
with  those who live with  with
us and along the entire
border
with whom we share a
common history and face the same
needs
with those peoples who
are our brothers
and who from one day to the next appeared
separated by a border strip,
Mr. President, Andrés Manuel López
Obrador, the agreement  signed
yesterday
in which
the tariffs scheduled to be
applied to our country in the coming
days are indefinitely suspended, it is a clear sign
that good neighborliness is not due to
intimidation or threats or
weakening the genuine aspirations of
development  that has united our
peoples for many years
, which is why we are here today as a people
to celebrate the strength of dialogue and
of reason that the government of Mexico,
led by you,
always put you at the table
with the first fruits of respect and  dignity
all of us who are gathered here
know you
and we are on the northern border the
link  tion with our sisters and
brothers who have come to contribute their
work the gratitude of the
neighboring country and we understand that the contribution
of everything has been to mentally join those three kilometers of border for
the growth of the two nations
, Mr.
President, more than a strong source of
water
from a source of anguish and anxiety
should be a view like the one that is
thousands of kilometers of unity of
fraternity of solidarity and
strength is not there
because in our composition the
borders are sacred they are spaces of
communication with our gods and
our ancestors and they are
sacred spaces also because
communication between human beings begins there,
we indigenous peoples think that this is how
we should get to know each other in this and
any other border
like us, recognizing
our cultural and
linguistic diversities and at the same time affirming
our human unity,
that is why from here we reiterate to the  people
of the usa of america
to  visit us and get to know us,
we welcome you all with open arms
without distinction of any
kind,
to conclude, I would like to recall the
words of Mr. Benito Juárez
García, President of Mexico, the
Universal Zapotec Mexican Indigenous, who gave
his speech on July 15, 1867, when he
reinstated the powers of  the union of
the people and the government present that the
people and the government respect the
rights of all among individuals
as well as among nations respect for the
rights of others is peace
that
is why here
from the northern border we extend
our friendly hand and celebrate I feel
if  dialogue yes to dignity
yes to peace thank you very much without dignity
[Applause]
thank you resided we can take a seat let's
listen to the president of the council
business coordinator maestro carlos
salazar lomelín
Mr. President with your permission
dear governors friends
chamber of deputies- chamber of senators
all gathered here  on a day of great
happiness for the m  exicanos today
through your faces we see what
130 million mexicans feel you
represent that happiness that joy
that profit that our
mexico represents when it is united when it is
strengthened because the reason because the
arguments are what in the end
convinced everyone that we
we needed
the support of our entire society
around the president we couldn't
have a better setting than to observe that
flag that flag that unites us all
that flag that, when waved, seems
to envelop all of us Mexicans who,
always united with just causes,
can do what  what we should do
today we have learned two lessons
the first to remind ourselves that when
we mexicans unite when
we mexicans support each other when
we mexicans work together
we
always win we can always develop a better
country that
is why let us remember this afternoon as an afternoon of
united effort of dedication
afternoon where we all win because we are
around you, Mr. President, but
above all around that flag that
represents us and unites all of
us Mexicans that surround each of
us
second election we have to learn
going forward
we have to always make an effort to
combat the problems of our country
no one is going to  do favors
we are not going to win each one of us
let's not expect anything from anyone other than
our effort our dedication the
businessmen are around you
we want a better mexico a mexico where
poverty is eradicated where these
faces reflect the joy and desire of
what we can build together for this
great country in mexico where
we all work to make it fairer more
prosperous more united where we all put
but we all win that is the second
lesson that leaves us this afternoon with this
heat and with this human warmth
represented by
each one  I appreciate you,
President, who has invited me to this
meeting. I feel enormously satisfied.
having helped, as always, putting
the business sector at their side and
trying to build the mexico that
we all dream of, i feel enormously
satisfied to be in this
our northern border, which more than a
border that divides is a border that
finds and finds everyone  the
united Mexicans over there on the other side
are seeing us and they are seeing us like this
happy satisfied but above all
around a great leadership
I appreciate very much that they invited me
thank you very much to all of us
[Applause]
we can drink by doing let's
listen to the leader right away  from the
confederation of workers of mexico
carlos acevedo
[Music]
lópez obrador
afternoon distinguished members of the
presidium
good afternoon to all of
you
the evangelical christian churches
agglutinated in the
national fellowship of evangelical christian churches
come to give your
unconditional support to the  president of mexico
because in the united states it is a nation  ion
founded with biblical christian principles
those who founded the american union
expelled from england
the famous quakers pure
men men of integrity men of principles and
values came to sow the seed of the w
rd of god in this great nation and for t
is it says on the dollar in god
We trust and I want to widely congratulate
the delegation of the federal government,
all those who led and who did
an extraordinary job and that many
people,
some small sectors, gave little
hope for their success and
next Monday we would be in a
situation of national
crisis where the  5 percent
taxes with the tariffs that
had been announced but we thank
God who made heaven and earth
because God put order in both the
US government and the
Mexican government based on a
fundamental principle that is justice
and  social justice and what is
social justice social justice has  There are
two main aspects, one is
based on truth, social justice
number 2 is based on
equity, and I believe that both negotiating teams,
both the one from Mexico and the one from the United
States, spoke the truth
and said that each one had to do
so as not to destroy, no
neither mexico nor the usa harm each other but that these two
great nations can walk as two
brother peoples
by the grace of god we have principles
and values in the same way that trans
orm lives that make new men t
marriages to families to pe
ples justice  it enhances
the nation and I believe that with these
principles of justice that
both the Mexican and the
US delegations were exercising during these
negotiations that certainly there was not
much hope but that with faith and
hope they were the representatives of
Mexico and I want to ask them for a big round of
applause  recognition for the
Mexican delegation that achieved
stability next Monday  in mexico
[Applause]
we feel, Mr. President, andrés
manuel lópez obrador, proud of
social justice,
what is the fourth transformation that is
applied in the fourth transformation, that
is,
there is a principle of the wisest man
who said, open your mouth, judge with justice
and defend justice  Because of the poor and the
needy, we are proud of
you, Mr. President, that not
only the poor, as you say,
the poor
first, but also the
homeless children first, the widows first,
the elderly first, the young people first,
the peasants, we are proud
of this social justice.  that the fourth
transformation is being carried out
with all the social programs that
you are leading and that mexico
is currently undergoing this
wonderful transformation in such a way
that it is founded on these principles
of justice justice magnifies
the nation we feel proud  from
you, Mr. President of all your
cabinet because because they are not ashamed
of foreigners if we turn our
backs on foreigners we bring a
curse on us
this is a very important principle that
the most high god says if you do not help the
orphan the widow the homeless and the
foreigner brings a curse on you  We
are proud of this
social justice that leads the fourth
transformation that is bringing to the
more than 125 million Mexicans,
thank you very much, Mr. President, for standing up
for the poor, for the orphans, for the
foreigners, for the peasants, for the
young people, God bless  mexico
[Applause]
[Music] let's
listen to the human rights defender
father solalinde
very good afternoon to all
good afternoon to all the inhabitants of
mexico whether they are citizens or not
thank you and welcome to all the
authorities of the three levels of
government  I especially greet with great
affection my brother Andrés Manuel López
Obrador who is doing  endo history
also
and tell you that mexico is a
blessed and wonderful space blessed by a
great lady who is the virgin of
guadalupe
many things are grace of mind they have divided us
but here we are to unite we are an
expression of hope
we want to be participants actors of
a  new life for mexico we have been
carrying a lot of burdens we have been
carrying many divisions with a lot
of bad diversity that has confronted us
today we have the opportunity not only to
express in words our lesson
a great president if we do not want to
demonstrate with actions that
we really want to change all of mexico  and
we all have to do something on our part
mexico would not be complete in this
integral transformation if we did not do
what we have to do to strengthen the
spirituality that
our president has proclaimed so much and insisted on so much when
speaking of this revolution of
conscience that this country also has
wonderful germ of ethics we have to be
a  To Ethical Nation I want to address
all the Christian parishioners above
all and non-Christian ones I also want to address
the parishioners
who struggle to manifest and express their faith
in daily life
our country is going through a
very difficult situation we have been
experiencing pressures not  only of one
person but above all of a
neoliberal capitalist system that worships
money that worships the market that is its
true god we want
instead that we believe in the person in the
human being today we are seeing how
this humanitarian crisis of brothers comes from the south
and our sisters, mexico is
not going to turn its back on him, we have tried to
get out of that trance, but we have the great
opportunity to influence the true
solution, which is comprehensive development,
today we want to present a
great person who has to be a reference
for this  instead, this person is jesus
of nazareth, she is the one who is going to
help us, the one who is going to guide us so that we can
really  Let us build that kingdom that
our president wants and also our
brothers from the original peoples have
spoken of something wonderful, it is
dialogue, perhaps we have not considered it,
our president has said dialogue and
then dialogue and always dialogue
because dialogue is the sacrament of the kingdom of
god where we have to make the
revolution is in two spaces the
conscience so that it is really free with the
truth but also the
relationships where exactly the
future and the present and the future of
humanity are played out mexico has taken a great step it has
come out unscathed  of this dialogue but
we are always going to have goals and
we are always going to have those people who seek
the interest of money
in return I think we are looking for
that friendship from town to town that
twinning with the south and with the north
we could not be present nor
could we  To say that we are a nation that
we want to change, we want to transform ourselves
if it is not through good
relations, I would  I say that I feel very
hopeful, very proud of the
presence of each one of you, of each
one of you, and we are going to ask God
to help us achieve this
transformation, it will not be easy because
we have a lot of inertia but
we also have a lot of resistance because
unfortunately we have lived a
disastrous life but today we have the
opportunity to unite to achieve this
great
transformation women and youth but also
native peoples are a
beautiful reserve that will help us change
mexico today we know that half of the
servants of  Mexico are
women and this gives us
great hope because no, I am not
selling anyone out, but I think we
are very close to perhaps having the
first female national president, hopefully
it will be, thank you very much
[Applause]
and we can take a seat and
listen to the  message from the
constitutional governor of the state of querétaro and
president of the conago francisco
domíngue  z servién
[Applause]
Mr. Andrés Manuel López Obrador
President of the United
Mexican States Deputy Porfirio Muñoz Ledo
President of the Board of Directors of the
Chamber of Deputies of the 64th Legislature
Mr. Francisco Arturo Vega
Governor of Baja California
Head of Government
Head of Government of the  mexico city
governor governors of our country
maestro carlos salazar lomelín
president of the council
business coordinator of mexico
senators and senators
federal deputies federal deputies
local deputies local deputies
federal municipal state officials ladies
and gentlemen
today as in these moments history
mexico knew how to stand up to
face and overcome the challenges
I come on behalf of the 32
governors of the country to express a
categorical and firm message
when we Mexicans close ranks
and focus on similarities rather
than differences our country
is doing much better during  the hours
of restlessness and uncertainty
the us government found a
merged mexico on an unshakable footing we managed to
make the national interest
prevail dialogue prevailed intelligence
good sense mexico sends a powerful
message to the world it is necessary that
respect for the imposition of the imposition
understanding to mistrust and
argument to threat we are defenders
of a world without barriers
or ideas or prejudices we can
proudly affirm it,
we Mexicans do not accept walls or concrete or
tariffs
let us always remember
ideas and values are our only
eapons  we do not have others, but
there are no better ones, we are guided by
principles, openness, integration,
dignity and respect, dialogue is
listening to the other, attending to their
concerns, listening to their arguments,
accepting what is correct and
rejecting what affects us, no one
wins everything in a negotiation  or I know of everything to
negotiate without giving in is to impose
the result is that  today mexico is
going to be better it is stronger it is more
congruent and eliminated a threat that if it
had been fulfilled would have
seriously harmed them but the most
important thing today
mexico is reunited in unity we
all share the pride of
always singing a national anthem and saluting the
mexican flag  we are united by the desire to
live in freedom and in solidarity
that we believe that the only
possible neighborhood is cooperation, empathy,
respect that this border may not
divide and separate us but rather unite
and connect us if
good will prevails in our relationships we believe
in respect  as a form of coexistence
and neighborhood, the path built by
many good Mexicans but also by
many good North Americans, respect
for the good neighbor policy of the
alliance for the progress of the
signing of the free trade agreement, a society
is not fair or ceases to be  society
and we are partners of the usa we do not
aspire to more but we do not accept
less either  As Mexicans, we will
always defend the freedom to decide, to
progress, to invest, to export, to
guarantee that every Mexican home
lives better. We want a
more prosperous and fair North American region
where the benefits of belonging to
it are felt at every table in every
Mexican home.  a region that
respects democracy and
human rights law a
North American region that connects
with infrastructure with value chains
with many jobs with good salaries
with a region that is synonymous with
justice and well-being we have a duty to
ensure that mexico has a  place in
the world but also that the world
finds a place in our country
the time of isolation achieved we
tried it and it was left behind
this agreement is achieved by the integrity of
our people by the height of sights'
that he knew and will always know to put the
national interest before  that there will be Mexican men and women
who first embrace our
coincidences and let us forget between  e all of us
for a moment our differences to
all of us today we are united by a great love
and a great pride that is mexico but
this agreement was also achieved because there are
people in the us who believe, think and
feel the same as us we
confirm it there are more friends of mexico in
the usa that people who are suspicious of
our fraternity
call on them today to
reprimand them for our eagerness to maintain
a respectful and affable
relationship the relationship between mexico and the usa is much
more than deep, rich and generous than the
relationship between governments
governments change  Friends do not
know that the vast majority of
the American people respect the
principles they inherited from their founding fathers:
freedom, democracy,
justice, the governors will
strengthen relations with
our parents and we will ask
businessmen, society, academia,
the cultural sector to join
this policy in favor of a
worthy and solid association
that today mexico cel  It is here in Tijuana to
find ourselves united under a single voice
that knew how to defend justice,
freedom and democracy. We
acknowledge the negotiating team for
their temperance and firmness shown during
the negotiation and the agreement. I
also acknowledge
my colleagues and fellow
governors for  the solidarity and
commitment expressed around the
main objective that unites us all
our nation
at the same time we recognize the
efforts of the head of the Mexican state
andrés manuel lópez obrador
and of the entire Mexican society to
face with maturity and firmness these
hours of uncertainty this plaza  Even
you testify that unity makes us
stronger,
all of us, thousands of Mexican men and women
who love and protect our
military country.
discrepancies that divide us when it
comes to defending even  our country
above all is the national interest long
live justice and freedom long
live mexico
[Applause]
[Applause] let us
listen to the message of the deputy
president of the chamber of deputies
porfirio muñoz ledo
citizen president of the republic
ladies and gentlemen governors and
legislators
very dear people of tijuana
for 100 years
[Music]
bucareli treaties we did not have such a
troubled relationship
with the us government
the substitution of diplomatic language
for profanity and the exchange of a
friendly treatment
threatens that forces us to strengthen our
unity  before the national agreement for the
defense of the life of the country it is
proposed he presides
we aspire that at the end of this tunnel
our relationship with the united states will be
much better
than we had now there have been
very cordial moments
the governor to the good neighbors
summer heading
I hope you
expropriation  of oil and led us to
the second world war in alliance with the
us
today is a day  to celebrate
but also to reflect
and in the long run
we live in a new historical time that
of globality this requires the creation of
competitive regional economic blocks
the
equitable world that is super internal
we can hardly understand that trump
would like to dismantle
economic actions built for
so many  years
of
unpredictable tariffs on our economy
I want to refer to a main issue
we cannot accept that migration is
a cursed word
migration
is a human right
the
cds considers it that way in all the
constitutions of morelos and all the
international treaties on the
matter either  we can accept the
metro language
that does not want dialogue but actions
which means that it has no
intention of reaching a body they know that
we have the
force of reason and they the reason
of force
the reflections
more than 5 million
North American workers depend on the exchange
eat  cial is clear between us the
two countries there is no solution in an
interdependence the proof is the
border strip from tijuana in matamoros
where there is the best crossing of people in
a peaceful and orderly way that the whole
project
also exists the right to navigate
what creation means  of conditions
in their country of origin so that
citizens do not have to move to
other countries of all
mexico
long trusted in the
bilateral solution of our problems although
we could
have gone to the
world trade organization to the supreme court
the nations
I want to say
that the path we have found is the best
and I want to congratulate the negotiators
led by Marcelo Ebrard and
Marta Barrera, who had a patient attitude and
never allowed themselves to be infected.
In my opinion, it is
unacceptable to ignore
the double zero between the northern border
and the  from the south
on the one hand we demand that they open the
doors for us and on the other hand we seal the
step of the central americans to
do a dark favor to the united states
in the best mitigation of the exodus is the
substantive and progressive elevation
of living conditions through the
substantive increase in wages that is what we
achieved with canada and with the united states
he finally told me
our compatriots from abroad
with whom we have had for 50 years
the best reasons
they represent
our history and aspiration
mexico is a nation
that transcends its borders
in fact there are countries with several nations
and nations in several states
we could never value our
compact they are also  a replica
in the people of Queretaro and our
state authorities have taken care of him
and solidarity
we want a great homeland
there a Mexican finds them long
live the great Mexican nation
that our compatriots from
abroad live long live the good need
[Applause]
take  one hundred thanks presidio
now ladies and gentlemen let's hear the
m  Message addressed to us by the
constitutional president of the United Mexican States,
Mr. Andrés Manuel López
Obrador
[Music]
[Applause]
friends friends
from Tijuana
from Baja California
from Mexico
and from the United States
representatives
of the legislative power
the governors governor
head of government
state municipal public servants and  federal
representatives of indigenous communities
of peasant workers
carlos salazar representative
president of the council business coordinator
representatives
of free churches
migrant thinkers
friends all of the
usa and mexico are not
distant neighbors they
share a
three thousand one hundred and eighty kilometer long border they
exert a mutual cultural influence
and the national histories of our
countries
are
among the sagas
in numerous episodes
of hostility but also
of cooperation and understanding,
the great blow
of 1847
and the interventions of the 20th century in
our territory, in addition to
other  you
have had a counterpart
in the friendship
between governments and the fraternity of the
peoples of both nations,
for
example, president benito juárez,
the best president of mexico,
received invaluable help
from abraham lincoln in his fight against
the french invaders
and at other times the
us
gave  refuge
to heroes of our history such
as mariano escobedo vicente
rivapalacio francisco y madero and jose
vasconcelos
we do not forget
and they ignored the victorian usurper
huerta
in 1913 who had seized power
after a coup d'état
plus water
many journalists social and
political leaders of our  country
chose to fight the Porfirista dictatorship
from the United States
to save their lives because at that
time, while the law was applied in the United States
and they were punished with prison,
unfortunately in Mexico they were shot
in the back, the famous
and terrible  leak law
later
as it has been said here  he governments
of franklin delano roosevelt and lázaro
cárdenas maintained
exemplary relations despite the
oil expropriation of 1938 a few years later
mexico fought alongside the united states
in world war ii not only with
the
heroic mexican aviators of the 201 squadron who
fought in the pacific  but also
sending back workers to the neighboring country at that time
who
helped guarantee the production of food
and raw materials in the us
in the middle of the last century
technology and capital goods
from our neighbors to the
north were essential for the
industrialization process promoted
In our country
towards the 1960s,
the programs for the
development of the northern border began with the
progressive bilateral commercial support
with the growth of our economy and
the internal market, the US companies
found an attractive
investment area in our country and almost
all major corporations  ations established
subsidiaries in our cities
in 1993, both countries, in addition to Canada,
signed the North American Free Trade Agreement,
which
constituted one of the main
economic blocs in the world.
Consequently, in 1995, the
Washington government granted extraordinary financial support
to  overcome the
economic crisis the devaluation of the peso the
financial crisis that occurred at the
end of the administration of carlos
salinas and the beginning of that of ernesto zedillo
[Music]
one
of the
consequences of the imposition of
the neoliberal model in our country was the
massive expulsion of the population from  their
places of origin the loss of jobs
in a dismantled industry
when they said that the best industrial policy
was
the one that did not exist
and thus with the abandonment of
productive activities in the countryside in
the city the flow of economic refugees grew
and as they never had  to go look for
life on the other side of the border, a
thousand  Millions of Mexicans,
millions of our compatriots,
crossed the Rio Bravo in search of
economic subsistence and better
horizons of life and had to
face discrimination,
outrages and police persecution,
but also and we must not
ignore that there were also sublime
demonstrations of support and  solidarity
of a large part of American society
today the us has a
mexican community made up of some 36
million people, of which 15
million were born in mexico that
population makes a fundamental contribution
to the economy and culture of the
neighboring country and its  political participation there
is increasingly relevant there are
more than a million
entrepreneurs in it in addition the mexicans
carry out 30 percent of the
agricultural work in the us, 20 percent of
the construction tasks and 15
percent in the tourist industry in
counterpart these compatriots
contribute to the Mexican economy with
remittances  For more than 33 billion
dollars a year,
a little-cited fact is that in Mexico
there are about one million two hundred
thousand Americans, that is, our
two countries are protagonists of the largest
demographic exchange in the world,
moreover, as well as the neighboring nation, it
is the main destination  for
mexican exports to sell
goods that are produced in
mexico our nation is also the
most important market for
us exports it is in this
context and on the eve of the conclusion
of the
us mexico and canada treaty that it is presented
to the  unilateral decision by the president
of donald trump to impose a
generalized and progressive tariff on
mexican exports to the
united states- it is a measure that
we respect but that we do not share
because if applied it would have caused, as
has been said here, significant damage to
both economies and
significantly weakened the region's trade alliance
by fostering  Fortunately, from the beginning we made
proposals to the US government
to fundamentally resolve the
migratory phenomenon and that contributed a lot to the
intense negotiations that were held
in Washington. To reach
yesterday's agreement, it also paid for the determined position
of maintaining a policy of respect and
good neighborliness with  the us government and
in brotherhood with its population
take the opportunity
here in tijuana
to tell the american people
once again that we do not harbor and will
harbor no intention of
harming them and that we are resolved to
collaborate with them in all areas,
especially given the concern
raised by the  growth of the
migratory flow towards your country,
likewise we come to your understanding
because the migratory phenomenon does not arise out
of nowhere, it is caused by
material shortages and insecurity in
the Central American countries and in
marginalized sectors and regions of
Mexico where
human beings
who need to undertake  a whole
pilgrimage  To mitigate their hunger and
poverty or to preserve their lives,
we have stated that we will solve the
migratory phenomenon by attacking its root causes,
that is, by
promoting development and the construction of
well-being and peace, and in Mexico
we are already doing it, but to apply
this proposal  in the nations of
central america and the caribbean the support of the united states of america and canada and other developed countries is essential i want to mention a moving fact about the 521 thousand migrants who entered our country through the southern border
this year with the intention of
reaching the usa
159 1,395 are minors
and 43,875
girls and boys traveled alone it
is clear that in the face of this bitter reality
this bitter and painful reality
cannot face
the solution just to close borders or
use coercive measures the most
effective and the most humane thing is  address the
migratory phenomenon by combating the lack
of employment opportunities and poverty
to ensure that  Migration is
optional and not forced. Consequently, we
reaffirm our commitment to
help prevent migrants from
crossing national territory to
reach the United States, but
we will never do so by violating the human rights
of travelers,
starting with the main
human rights, the right to live
free.  of misery the right
to life
under this criterion
that we will
always uphold it
will always be unfair to try to
punish mexico for proposing a stop to
migration by promoting
well-being and security in their points
of origin and for seeking brotherhood
between societies  and the peoples
celebrated yesterday's important agreement
because it
was putting us in a
very difficult, very
uncomfortable situation of having to apply
the same
trade restrictions measures similar to
those that were going to be imposed on
exports to certain US merchandise  Mexicans
I confess
that as a person as a citizen
he rejected acts of retaliation
and the retaliation law i am a
convinced pacifist inspired
by gandhi's examples
of martin luther king from the sun
mandela
however
as head and representative of the
mexican state i cannot
allow anyone to attack the economy of
our  country and
unless an unjust asymmetry is established that is
unworthy of
our government and humiliating for
our nation
fortunately yesterday the
policy
of confrontation was imposed and I must recognize
your willingness to seek a
negotiated solution to the conflict on the part of the
president of donald trump and his
main  collaborators I know
the president of donald trump
that is why
I raise
a clenched fist but rather an open and frank hand
we reiterate
our disposition to friendship,
dialogue and collaboration we
also express our
determination to stay out
of the internal affairs of our
neighboring country
close to the  same time
near neighbor
usa e  Congruence with our policy
of principles of non-intervention
and self-determination of peoples,
that there is no foreign interference in
decisions that only concern the
sovereignty of our people,
I am, like you
and like many Mexicans, proud of the
professional political and
diplomatic work of the delegation  mexican
who was in charge of this complex and
difficult issue
led by the secretary of
foreign affairs of mexico marcelo
ebrard
[Applause]
as he himself put it it
is easy to understand
on monday there will be no more tariffs there
will be no taxes there will not be
economic or financial crisis in our
country
[Applause]
also
and the solidarity
of the people of Mexico
of the Mexicans the people of Mexico is a
lot of piece
[Music]
I would like to say no more things about that
but I have to limit myself I
appreciate the solidarity
of all the  social classes of
all sectors
of all currents of thought
of all  s mexicans who did not hesitate
to express their support in defending
the dignity of our country
at the same time
with great political maturity
preserve friendship with the people of the
united states
what follows
punctually fulfill commitments
commitments are fulfilled reinforce our
border apply the law and  respect
human rights promote
the immediate application
of the eclac development program to boost
productive activities and create jobs
in central america and south-southeast
mexico next week
we will be offering
humanitarian aid
employment opportunities education health and well-being to
those who wait in mexico for their
asylum application to legally enter the
usa
added
that there are unbeatable political conditions
to achieve, in a timely
manner and according to
the rule of law that prevails in the
country with autonomy from the powers
that be, i can say that i am almost sure of the
ratification in the chamber of
senators of the  state of free trade between
mexico, united states, and canada, my
friends, not even
today, as I have done for many years, to
tour the municipalities of Baja
California,
now they
are our hosts, they
are the ones who allowed us to carry
out this act of unity here, where our country begins
,
for that
it was this convocation once again
I thank all the
representative sectors of the people of Mexico
for their support for their solidarity I
am very grateful to
the media in our
country that despite the fact that we may have
differences because we live in a
free country and we aspire to  build a
democracy, not a dictatorship, and
the right to dissent must always be guaranteed
despite differences, the
information media in our country
rose to the occasion
[Applause
] friends,
as we all know,
this
is
in the public domain Mexico  it is a country with
many natural riches with a
noble and hard-working people
we have the heritage  ity
of great civilizations and cultures that
practice an extraordinary social ethic
[Music]
that
the ear has left us that is how they have inherited the
habit of work
the best workers in the United States are the
Mexicans
[Applause]
and
our ancestors inherited us as a major lesson
the  putting love of neighbor first
mutual aid
where does
the mutual aid of the
native peoples of the indigenous communities
come from far from deep mexico
and
they remember what our parents repeated to us
our grandparents what was said
in the villages  the word spread from mouth to
mouth they
said to do good without looking at who
they remember that
that entails all the greatness
of our country of our great nation
if despite our differences as
we demonstrated this week
in these days
we act as here  he has also said
all together without hatred with honesty
with humanism and a sense of justice
we will be stronger and stronger in the
c  concert of nations and always
capable of overcoming any adversity
to consummate sooner rather than later the
great objective of building a
new,
peaceful and fraternal prosperous homeland in which
the ideal reigns forever the ideal means
of well-being and happiness
of the people who live  mexico
lives in mexico
[Applause]
m
our glorious national anthem
[Music]
[Applause
] The President of
the United Mexican States,
Mr. Andrés Manuel, bids you farewell  lópez obrador
mexico thanks you for your kind
assistance
excellent afternoon
[Applause]
[Music]